bonjour gérard haas merci de répondre
aux questions sur arte france que risque
criteo on parle d'une amende de 4 % du
chiffre d'affaires annuel mondial du
géant de la publicité français alors
c'est exact dans le cadre du règlement
général la protection des données
l'article 4 qui définit en fait ce qui
est le consentement implique que le
consentement soit un consentement libre
et spécifiques univoque et éclairé et
dans ce cadre-là la sanction peut aller
jusqu'à vingt millions d'euros ou 4 % du
chiffre d'affaires mondial
les comptes de criteo sont dans le rouge
depuis l'année dernière que peut
invoquer la société pour sa défense si
vous voulez c'est un enjeu aujourd'hui
important en matière de cookies parce
que l'objectif criteo est une société
c'est ce qu'on appelle un data broker
cette enquête il faut le rappeler est
mené aussi en irlande et en angleterre
en angleterre et il n'y a que criteo la
cnil 6 criteo mais il y a aussi des
sociétés comme axium comme un contraste
date at crédit score et qui fox ou
expérience et si vous voulez ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que lorsque
vous allez sur un site internet en
cliquant j'accepte et en acceptant un
coût qui en fait on ne vous informe pas
de l'ensemble des traitements qui vont
être partenaires qui vont vous suivre
et c'est ce qui a fait la fortune de
criteo et bien entendu donc il y adhérer
à cela un problème est ce que j'aime
bien donner mon consentement est ce
qu'il était libre éclairé et ccsa tout
l'enjeu de l'enquète cela porte à cinq
le nombre d'entreprises épinglé par le
collectif
prévue ici international donc une ong
britannique donc à travers l'europe
qu'est-ce que ça traduit selon vous que
le rg est facile à contourner ou
qu'il ya une prise de conscience des
consommateurs sur la violence la
violation de leur vie privée
alors vous me posez une très très bonne
question c'est pas facile à contourner
puisque on voit aussi que les grandes
plateformes telles que google apple
amazon facebook ont déclaré et qu' il
allait aussi supprimer les cookies
tierces et donc on se rend compte que
c'est quand même le phénomène qui est
planétaire
en revanche c'est vrai que aujourd'hui
et cette plainte elle et elle va dans ce
sens là le suivi de l'application de la
réglementation faisait des troupes
puisque dans la plainte il est il a été
considéré que en fait l'acceptation
était trompeur
en fait on ne dit pas jusqu'où on va et
ce que l'on suit donc il va falloir voir
un petit peu les moyens que va présenter
criteo pour montrer qu'en fait les
personnes sont clairement renseigner et
les met les moyens qui lui a à faire
puisque l'objectif c'est des cookies
tierces
c'est pas les cookies de première main
donc c'est aussi l'enjeu qui lie à pour
tous sur au ciblage publicitaire et est
ce que cette enquête de la cnil peut
dissuader les autres sociétés de
procéder de la sorte
évidemment la longue enquête elles
montrent que le secteur de dea doit
d'aider à theix qu'on appelle les
attaques étaient sous surveillance
et évidemment je pense que là c'est une
vraie honte de choc
c'est un vrai uvrer onde de choc et qui
est lancé et effectivement le ce secteur
ne va se redynamiser et pour se re
dynamiser il doit appliquer les règles
strictes aux 106 sans essayer de les
contourner ou de donner des informations
qui sont j'allais dire le tronc buzz
merci j'ai hâte d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en nouvelles
technologies